alain dionne et poissonniers depuis 13
ans dans un supermarché
la suspension de la prime de 2 $ l'heure
accordés durant la pandémie par son
employeur le rend amer c'est vocale est
passée la pandémie continue pareil c'est
de porter des masques et c'est pas vrai
a trahi comme celui des fayyad pour
personnes non plus mais on va essayer de
ne pas mobile avec pareil pour lui
travailler en ces temps de pandémie est
difficile avec les masques on est au
final en dessous du seuil c'était de me
gifler vexin lethu ac principal syndicat
du secteur estime que cette prime a
surtout démontré l'importance de ces
métiers à l'intention de transporter
cette discussion là au tas de
négociation de ceux ci une chose que la
cover nous a démontré c'est le sait la
valeur important de tous ces
travailleurs look chez olymel les
employés ont été informés au début du
mois de juin de l'arrêt de la prime
qu'ovide l'entreprise explique son choix
par la nécessité de revenir à la normale
c'est un effort financier considérable
c'est un effort pour encourager nos
employés a traversé une période où
c'était pas toujours évident de venir au
travail tous les matins et puis on a
ajouté hassan ou énormément de coups
pour l'application de mesures sanitaires
les mesures sanitaires seront appliquées
tant que la santé publique l'exigera par
ailleurs des enseignes de distribution
alimentaire ont décidé d'offrir des
bonus supplémentaires à leurs employés
alain dionne en bénéficiera un montant
forfaitaire de 2 à 300 dollars ce que
j'attendais de la télé mais c'est pour
combien de temps si ça dure six mois ça
fait pas grand chose pour six motos ça
d'abord comme pm ne sait pas grand chose
c'est ridicule au delà de la crise c'est
la valorisation de leur travail comme
essentiel que ces employés souhaiterait
voir valoriser non seulement en temps de
crise mais tout au long de l'année ici
s1000 khayat radio canada montréal